arrières cibray savoir quel deux courses
et je vis que l'aca retrouve en deux
fois et je croyais que c'était la terre
j'avais dit ça fait un rond l'acr
entourée d'un serpent mais je ne peux
pas exactement dire ce que c'est quoi
moi je dis un chien qui s'est oublié ou
alors à chirurgien qui ce n'est tout sur
l'estomac est censé être une allégorie
êtes sensible à oui je suis sensible
parce que je me dis quand même pour une
femme qui a tu as vu manipuler cette
matière et il a fallu quand même quelle
qu'elles travaillent énormément je crois
l'activité et non est-ce que je suis pas
assez qualifiés pour pardeza 1
mais personnellement je le donnerai gens
voudraient qu'on l'a vécu son enfance
aussi je le connais pas l école avec
quels sont les projets non non cotées
sont très bien vous dire que oui qui ont
une expression qu'on voit quelque chose
mais là vraiment ça me semble absolument
à rien